après trois mois de pause estivale les
députés rapportent à Ottawa les
préoccupations économiques de leurs
électeurs
le prix de la viande des légumes des
fruits c'est plus en plus cher parce que
les médicaments les inquiétudes qui
trouvent écho aux communes
des munitions pour le nouveau chef de
l'opposition officielle pour sa première
question en français les Canadiens ne
peuvent plus payer
est-ce que le premier ministre va
annuler ces augmentations de taxes sur
les aînés et sur les travailleurs pas de
duels avec juste un Trudeau qui est en
voyage à l'ONU une réplique donc qui
vient de ces ministres argent dans les
poches des Canadiens quand ils ont
besoin pour marquer la rentrée les
libéraux déposent finalement leur plan
de lutte contre l'inflation tout le
monde ressent durement l'effet de
l'augmentation du coût de la vie pour
les moins lentilles
crédit de tps doublé jusqu'à 460 dollars
de plus pour un couple avec deux enfants
un soutien supplémentaire arriveront 11
millions de personnes pour ceux qui
peinent à payer le loyer paiement unique
de 500 dollars pour les familles à
faible revenu jusqu'à 650 dollars par
enfant par année pour les soins
dentaires on estime que le programme
pourrait aider jusqu'à 500 000 enfants
canadiens coût total des nouvelles
mesures 4 milliards et demi de dollars
mais il y a des taxes qui sont chargées
de l'autre côté donc ça améliore pas de
situation de personnes est-ce qu'il va
falloir que je revienne à ce qui se
passait dans le temps va te falloir que
je prenne une pince pour aller arracher
la dent de mon fils moi c'est ce que
j'ai entendu chez nous puis c'est pas ça
qu'on veut faire avec on veut aider les
Canadiens les plus vulnérables et ceux
qui sont pas d'accord avec ça je vous
dirais que c'est des gens qui ont
podcast bref le temps monte d'un cran
après la nouvelle publicité du NPD qui
attaque pierre poirievre
dit je suis défenseur des familles filet
de travailleurs mais si on regarde le
bilan monsieur pollièvre
systématiquement il s'est rangé du côté
des grandes compagnies des pétrolières
de leur côté les libéraux promettent
pour le moment de rester courtois je
suis prêt de d'agir dans une façon en
raisonnable avec une tonde respectueuse
l'inflation semble ralentir et la connu
un deuxième recule de suite au mois
d'août mais la pression demeure sur le
portefeuille des Canadiens Pierre
paulièvre lui veut porter ce flambeau
aux communes et son premier face à face
avec Justin Trudeau sur la question est
attendu jeudi ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada Ottawa